come on Jaylen oh why I feel like I'm
running a mile you ain't going nowhere
I'm Trey young here with my friend
Jaylen Johnson we both have the day off
so we're going to try some pickle ball
With a Little Help from our Wells Fargo
active cash credit
cards what's up my guy how's it going
good we trying to run it pickleball
court for an hour be Court 14 I'll take
your payment right here all right cool
play before not serious I play maybe
once or twice what about you maybe once
but no I'm not no Pro I don't really
have much experience playing pickle ball
we're going to try to prevent the ice
tray celebration today you may see it if
I get the win you know let's get
it there's no warm-ups let's just go
ahead and play man what we play to what
we play to 11
[Music]
H oh let's out something wrong with my P
all right I know what it is hold on it's
too sunny out here dog we're both super
competitive in basketball in in this
pickle ball game for
sure oh yeah see now I can see better
oh
snap oh oh oh why I feel like I'm
running a mile you ain't going nowhere
there were a couple similarities between
pickle ball and basketball constantly
moving back and forth you got to be on
your p's and q's I'm not chasing that
bro I mean he's got the advantage with
the long arms and the long legs put some
heat on it wow hey3 here we go hold
on lock
in
H it's a big shot Trey don't call it a
comeback come on jayen mess up one time
for me
please yeah make him run Trey oh
no game point we got him on the ropes
come on Jaylen he trying to make me rush
you know that's what they try to do when
you're at the free throw line at the end
of the game trying to hit those last
couple free throws look you giving him
rest time about to S home right
here make him run a little
bit make him run oh my gosh no
adios you got it man you clap P two
times man you already know the deal it
was a great game you know came out with
the dove so you going to make me have to
have you out here we going to play this
again when that rematch happens it's
going to be different we can go get some
food it's on me I'll buy you got your a
little nice cardio session in I'm over
here sweating hi can I get for you I'm
going to go from the kids menu and get
the chicken tenders I'm going to do the
chicken tenders as well you want to play
any more pickle ball before the season
start you know I might get a couple more
matches in maybe we run it back a couple
times here you guys go thank you these
are good I ain't going to lie yeah these
in fire what a fun day love hanging out
with Jaylen a meal always tastes better
you don't got to pay for it and I love
that we ear unlimited 2% cash rewards on
purchases with our Wells Fargo active
cash credit cards got you
bro